D DAY:
On November 18, 2022, Elizabeth
Holmes is scheduled to be sentenced for running
one of the biggest frauds on silicon valley. If
you’re not familiar with Elizabeth, she was the
founder of an ambitious biotech company called
Theranos. The company promised to revolutionize
blood tests by reducing blood samples to a single
drop a of blood. As someone who’s not the biggest
fan of needles, this sounds like an awesome idea
and it appears that millions of consumers and
investors agreed. At the peak, Theranos had
raised an impressive $724 million from VCs and
several notable investors. This included the
likes of Larry Ellison, the Walton family, Rupert
Murdoch, Carlos Slim, and Robert Kraft. From their
perspective, Theranos was probably a no brainer
investment. The goal of the company was easy to
grasp and it had extremely intelligent people
behind it like Elizabeth herselves. Elizabeth
was a Stanford chemical engineering drop out. I
mean this is the exact recipe for silicon valley
success stories. But, Theranos was anything
but a success story. While Theranos would
reach a valuation of up to $10 billion, it turned
out that Theranos was just one big house of cards
held together with lies and deception. And that
brings us to where we are today. Elizabeth and
her business partner, Ramesh “Sunny” Balwani are
each facing up to 20 years in prison and a fine of
$250,000 plus restitution for each count of
conspiracy and wire fraud. So, here’s exactly
how Silicon’s Valley’s biggest fraud was exposed
and the disastrous consequences that followed.
FOOLING EVERYONE:
Taking a look back, the story of Theranos’
downfall dates back to early 2015. At the time,
the company had already been around for 12 years,
but this doesn’t mean that Elizabeth was able to
keep up the fraud anywhere near that long. You
see, Thernaos had maintained a virtually non
existent public image up until 2013. So, for the
longest time, Elizabeth didn’t have to convince
the public of anything. She just needed to
convince a few dozen investors. Now, it’s
not easy to convince investors, but more times
than not, their primary objections relate to the
financial success of the company as opposed to the
legitimacy of the company itself. And when it came
to finances, this company was a grand slam. If
they truly did achieve what they were promising,
the company would probably be worth hundreds
of billions today. Combine this with several
heavyweight players on both the company side
and the investor side, not to mention the dozens
of patents, and it’s unlikely that any investor
considered the possibility of fraud all that much.
But, while Elizabeth was able to pull a quick
on one investors, her facade didn’t hold up all
that well in the face of public scrutiny. Theranos
couldn’t put off a public reveal forever though,
so in September of 2013, they made their first
public move by partnering with Walgreens. The
deal entailed slowing rolling out Theranos’
testing equipment across Walgreens nationwide.
While consumers had yet to really hear about this
company till now, it didn’t take long for many
of them to be convinced thanks to Elizabeth’s
marketing efforts. She would go on a spree of
interviews, and publications would very much play
into her framing. She would appear on the covers
of Fortune, Forbes, The New York Times Style
Magazine, and Inc. Forbes labeled her as the
youngest self made female billionaire in the world
and ranked her as the 110th richest American. But,
Theranos’ marketing wasn’t the only thing
that was one point, they’re pricing was also
on point. Naturally, you would expect that such a
revolutionary product would cost an arm and a leg,
but it was actually relatively affordable
and was largely covered by many notable
insurance companies such as Capital BlueCross
and AmeriHealth Caritas. All of this resulted
in 175,000 people buying 7.8 million test
results from Theranos. But, while Elizabeth
had the general public and investors completely
duped, the same could not be said about medical
experts. While they were massive proponents of
such advancements themselves, they couldn’t help
but feel that Theranos was pushing the bounds
of what was realistically possible with current
technology. One such skeptic was a Missouri-based
pathologist who took their concerns to an
investigative journalist named John Carreyrou at
the Wall Street Journal. As you guess, John had
no idea what he was about to discover, but as a
good journalist he followed this lead and started
investigating Theranos. He would eventually get in
contact with the former lab director of Theranos,
Adam Rosendorff, who would spill the beans
on Theranos. Over the next several months,
John would continue his investigation and
secure whistleblowers including Erika Cheung
and Tyler Schultz. Despite John’s efforts
to keep the investigation discrete though,
Theranos would eventually hear about it. Elizabeth
would go to Rupert Murdoch who actually owns the
Wall Street Journal and ask him to cancel the
story. But, this pressure to cancel the story
just convinced John even more that he needed to
publish it and that’s exactly what he would do.
THE TRUTH COMES OUT:
On October 16, 2015, the Wall
Street Journal would post an article titled “Hot
Startup Theranos Has Struggled With Its Blood-Test
Technology. Silicon Valley lab, led by Elizabeth
Holmes, is valued at $9 billion but isn’t using
its technology for all the tests it offers.” The
article revealed how Theranos was only using their
quote on quote “proprietary technology” for a
small fraction of their tests. This in itself
doesn’t have to be a problem per se. If they were
upfront about how the technology only works for a
small subset of exams and that they were still
working on expanding its scope, I think that
would’ve been completely understandable. But,
instead, they decided to keep up the facade that
their technology accomplished more than it really
did. They continued to collect small blood samples
even for tests that they couldn’t complete, and
they would simply dilute these samples and run it
through traditional machinery. As you would guess,
this often resulted it heavily skewed results. To
make things worse, their proprietary technology
wasn’t all that reliable in the first place, so
they really hadn’t accomplished much of anything.
Nonetheless, after this report was published,
Elizabeth would agressively deny all allegations
and threaten to sue John for defamation. But,
while Elizabeth was able to get away with lying
to investors and the public, she couldn’t get
away with lying to the FDA. The FDA would go
ahead and conduct their own investigation which
proved the accuracy of John’s entire report. At
this point, it was all but over for Theranos and
it was just a matter of waiting for the house of
cards topple over. In January of 2016, the Centers
for Medicare and Medicaid Services or CMS would
send a warning letter to Theranos instructing them
to fix the irregularities across their testing.
But, within just two months, this polite warning
turned into a threat. The CMS proposed banning
Elizabeth from the laboratory industry for two
years. And just three months later, this proposal
would turn into action. Elizabeth would of course
try appealing this decision, but that didn’t get
her anywhere. In the meantime, Walgreens would
end their relationship with Theranos and close
all of their instore blood collection centers.
The FDA would also ban the use of Theranos'
infamous nanotainers which essentially wiped out
Theranos’ entire business. They had no product
left to sell and no one willing to sell it,
so Theranos had no option but to start laying off
all their employees. At their peak in late 2015,
they had a total of 800 employees but by
April of 2018, the had less than two dozen
employees. And most of these employees would
be laid off by August as well. At this point,
it was clear that even if Theranos did
figure out blood tests with microsamples,
the company’s reputation was so bad that
they could simply never recover. So, with
no choice left, on September 4, 2018, Theranos
announced that they were going to dissolve.
THE FALLOUT:
While the company
has been shutdown for years now, the repercussions
of their actions are still very much present with
multiple lawsuits ongoing. One of the first
entities to take action against Theranos was
the state of Arizona in 2017. They alleged that
the company had sold 1.5 million misleading blood
tests in the state, and Theranos would end up
settling for $4.65 million. Arizona wasn’t the
only one that was suing Theranos either.
Shareholders were of course also livid and
wanted to recoup as much as possible. But a
judge would actually rule that investors were
not eligible to pursue a class action lawsuit
against Thernos. You see, securities laws are
intended to protect retail investors from public
companies, but Theranos wasn’t a public company
and its investors weren’t retail. So, this made
the investors ineligible to sue under federal
securities laws. The investors tried getting
around this by suing under California state laws,
but the judge struck this down as well. With
their legal options exhausted, most Theranos
shareholders would just write off the investment
as a loss and move on or settle for pennies on the
dollar. Rupert Murdoch, for example, invested $125
million into Theranos and ended selling back his
shares for just $1. He did receive $4 million when
the other shareholders came to a settlement with
Theranos, but he still lost $121 million or 97%.
And this was the same case with most investors
except Elizabeth herself who has actually been
living it up. After being pushed out of Theranos,
Elizabeth turned around and starting dating Billy
Evans who is the heir to the Evans Hotel Group.
They have since gotten married and even had
a kid together. They currently live in a $135
million estate in Silicon Valley. If you just
saw her lifestyle today, you would think that
Theranos was a massive success. But, the most
trippy part is that one of her neighbors is
Larry Ellison. Imagine being scammed for tens
of millions if not hundreds of millions and
then the scammer moves in next door. Fortunately,
Larry owns two dozen properties in Malibu alone,
so he can stay far away from Elizabeth, but I’d
be surprised if this didn’t bother him atleast a
little. Anyway, while Elizabeth has been able to
escape investor accountability for the most part,
the same cannot be said about the criminal
lawsuits against her. In June of 2018, the
DOJ charged Elizabeth and her COO with 11 counts
of criminal felony. And at the beginning of 2022,
she was convicted on three charges of wire
fraud and one count of conspiracy to commit
wire fraud. And that brings us to where we
are today. Elizabeth is currently free on a
$500,000 bond and is waiting for sentencing that’s
scheduled for November 18, 2022. While she faces
up to 20 years in prison, most experts doubt
that she’ll actually serve anywhere near that
amount. However, it’s also unlikely that she’ll
be able to get away with no prison time. The most
likely scenario is that she ends up serving
less than 10 years at a low security prison.
FAKE IT TILL YOU MAKE IT:
In the end, while Elizabeth
Holmes has become infamous as one of the largest
fraudsters in silicon valley, she didn’t actually
do anything that out of the box. She was really
just trying to fake it till she made it which
is extremely common in silicon valley. If she had
a few more years, it’s possible that she would’ve
actually developed the technology for real. And
even if the truth about the early days did surface
after that, it wouldn’t have done anything.
It would’ve probably just been some sort of
fine and Theranos would still be up and running.
This is probably what Elizabeth was hoping for,
but unfortunately, she tried this strategy in the
wrong industry. If she had tried this strategy in
the tech industry, she probably could’ve gotten
away with it. But, the reason this works in the
tech industry is because the consequences
of not delivering aren’t that significant.
Worst case scenario, you take a reputational
hit, lose clients, and might get sued. But,
in the medical industry, Elizabeth was literally
playing with lives. Doctors were making life
changing medical decisions based on test results
from Theranos and the consequences of this can
never truly be measured. And this alone makes
Elizabeth’s actions criminal and inexcusable,
but that’s just what I think. What do you think
Elizabeth’s punishment should be? Comment that
down below. Also, drop a like if you wish
someone actually developed this for real.
And of course, consider checking out
our discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered.